اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفات هذا المساء ما
وراء قرار طهران وقفه تزويد دمشق بالنفط
منخفض السعر تعثر الاقتصاد الايراني ام
محاوله ضغط على نظام السوري في الملف
الثاني هل تشكل الوثائق السريه ازمه لبيض
على غرار ترامب وهل تعرقل خطط الرئيس
الامريكي الذي يفكر بالترشح لولايه
الرئاسيه جديده
وقف دراسه للاجئين السوريين بسبب اضرابات
المعلمين بلبنان عادل بهدف المساواه او
ظالم لعدم تحمل بيروت تكلفه تعليم
اللاجئين
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل ازمه خانقه تلقي
بظلالها على الاقتصاد السوري سببها
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه الجديده التي تسعى
لوضع قيود على توريد النفط رخيص الى دمشق
فبحسب صحيفه السجون الفان طهران ضعفت
السعر الذي تدفعه دمشق مقابل النفط الخام
مما ادى الى نقص الوقود في سوريا
فقد تسبب النقص في تشكل طوابير امام محطات
الوقود بعد ان رفعت ايران فعليا السعر من
30 الى اكثر من 70 دولار للبرميل بحسب
والسجون كما رفضت ايران تسليما شحنه جديده
بالدين وذكرت الصحيفه ان سوريا ستدفع
مقدما مقبل امدادات النفط الجديده
المتابعون للعلاقات بين البلدين قسموا
تحرك الايراني الجديد زينب من يرى ان
طهران كانت تستخدم النقد والاسعار
المتدينه للنفط في حمله لتوسيع نفوذها في
سوريا وبالتالي الخطوه التي اقبلت عليها
تفسر على انها ورقه ضغطه ثم يرى اخرون ان
الاقتصاد المتعثره في ايران هو نتيجه
العقوبات الغربيه المفروضه هو الذي دفعها
لاتخاذ مثل هذه الخطوه في محاوله لاعاش
وجاء القرار ليعكس تراجع طهران عن قرار
كانت اتخذت قبل اشهر بسيادتك كميات النفط
الى سوريا في خطوتين قالت انها تهدف الى
مساعدته دمشق على تجاوزه ازمه الطاقه
[موسيقى]
ونقش هذا الموضوع
عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي ومن
واشنطن الدكتور حسن هاشميان الباحث في شان
الايراني اهلا بكما واسمح لي ان نبدا بفهم
هذا القرار الايراني من عندك من واشنطن
دكتور حسن دكتور حسن ايران تتخذ بحسب
الوسط يجون طبعا اتخذت قرارا اول برفع سعر
النفط اتخذت كذلك قرار ثاني لا يقل
الاهميه عن هذا القرار الاول وهو ان تطلب
همم تسليمها هذا السعر مقدما
وترفض الاعتماد او اعتماد صيغه الائتمان
التي اعتمدتها عن النظام السوري لفتره
طويله ما الاسباب وراء هذا القرار
نعم تحياتي لكم الكريم ومشاهد البرنامج
انا اعتقد هناك اسباب داخليه وايضا اسباب
تتعلق
بالعلاقه بسوريا وخاصه
الانفتاح الجديد لسوريا على تركيا
اعتقد هناك طبعا مجموعه كبيره من المدراء
في ايران وازلام النظام كانوا ينتغلون هذا
الموضوع بان يعطونا مجاني لسوريا وموضوع
النفط المجاني الى سوريا حتى كان من ضمن
الشعارات في المظاهرات والاحتجاج
30 دولار للبرميل ليس مجانين خاصه وانا
ايران تكسر بهذه الطريقه عقوبات امريكيه
مفروض عليها
بالتاكيد هو طبعا 30 دولار ولكن كان اكثر
من النصف لاسعار الدوليه ولكن ما يجري في
الشارع الايراني بان بشار الاسد هو ياخذ
نفط الايراني بصوره مجانيه ولكن انا اعتقد
ان الموضوع الثاني والعلاقه بين بشار
الاسد والتركيه اثرت في الاونه الاخيره
اعتقد عندما طرحت الموضوع قبل
عامين هناك كانت همم زيارات مكوكيه لعبد
الله ايام الى دمشق اكثر من خمس مرات عبد
الله ايام الزهراء الدماش وايضا فيصل
المقداد وزاره طهران ثلاث مرات وايضا نرى
انه طهران وايران لم يتم دعوته الى
الاجتماع الثلاثي بين روسيا وتركيا وسوريا
وهذا واضح ان النظام الايراني منزعج تماما
من يا رب التركي السوري وواضح انه لا يريد
يحصل هذا التقارب لان ليس في مصلحتين همم
انفتاح التركي على سوريا سيغير بعض
الموازنات ايران ستصبح البلد الثالث في
سوريا بعد روسيا وتركيا وايضا موضوع اعاده
اللاجئين ليس من صالح النظام الايراني
وتغير همم العلاقه بين الجانبين هو الذي
فرض مثل هكذا قرار ما رايك استاذ عبد
الحميد
مساء الخير
والساده المشاهدين اعتقد ان جمله الظروف
القائمه الان ااا
الان انكماش الايراني في تزويد سوريا
بالنفط لم ياتي متزامنا مع الانفتاح
التركي على سوريا او حاله التقاربه
والتصالح التي تجري الان انما هي سبقتها
هذه اشواط كثيره سوريه تعاني منها نقص
نعم
استاذ عبد الحميد يبدا بان الصوره
اعاده الصوت تفضل استاذ عبد الحميد
اقول بان التوريدات النفطيه من ايران
قد تقلصت وشحت كثيرا في خلال السنه ونصف
او السنتين الاخيرتين ولكن في هذه المرحله
لا شك بان هناك عده عوامل عده الى
الدفع بهذا الاتجاه الى وضعه في اطار
الممارسه الضغوط او محاوله الابتزاز او
الوصول الى اهداف سياسيه في الحقيقه لا
يمكن فصل هذا الجانب عن الاهداف السياسيه
بين دولهتين سواء كانت سوريا وايران
كيف ذلك والبعض يقول بان هناك تقاربا
عميقا همم ومصالح مشتركه بين الجانب
السوري والجانب الايراني حتى ان البعض
باعتقاده بان ماذا تتحدث به سوريا هو همم
يعني همم
يمنع عليها من الجانب الايراني انصح
التعبير
ولا ينكر هذا الامر منذ عام 1979 تجلت هذه
العلاقه وتاثر في همم قطر مختلفه سياسيه
واقتصاديه وعسكريه وامنيه وحتى على مستوى
السياحه والاجتماع والى اخره العلاقه
العميقه هذه ادت الى ان توضع اسس لبناء
هذه العلاقه في الارض الاخيره في العقد
الاخير من الزمن بعد همم الاحداث في سوريا
تغيرت العلاقه وتطورت فكانت هناك مشاركه
ايرانيه واضحه وملموسه في على الارض
السوريه عسكريه واقتصاديا ولكن بعد العام
2018 والهزه الاقتصاديه الكبيره ومفاعيل
الضغوط الاقتصاديه والعقوبات الاقتصاديه
على ايران بدات هذه المساله تظهر الى
العلن وبعد التنعكس على الحاله السوريه
فيما يتعلق بتوريدات الطاقه والنفط انا
اعتقد بان اليوم العنصر الاخر العامل
الاخر اذا هناك عامل
دور
سياسيين فقط ولكن هو من خلال هذه الركائز
الاقتصاديه
الاقتصاديه تتحدث بها ايران وظرف داخلي
تحدث به منذ قليل الدكتور حسن وقال بانه
هناك ضغوط من داخل الايراني ولكن دكتور
حسن هل تعتقد حذرتك بانه هذا الملف قد
يعطل مسار المحادثات او على الاقل قد يربك
العلاقات الثنائيه بين الدولتين او انه
كما تفضل بالاشاره الاستاذ عبد الحميد بان
هذه العلاقه متوتره منذ فتره وما هذا
القرار الا نتيجه لتوتر هذا هذه العلاقه
يعني هو صحيح عن النظام الايراني كان له
حضور عسكري وامني في سوريا ولكن لا نستطيع
ان نقول انه لديه ااا حضور اقتصادي قوي في
سوريا
وعلى سبيل المثال هناك اتفاقيات كانت بين
الجانب الايراني والجانب السوري مثلا
اتفاقيه النقل اتفاقيه اعفاء ضريبه ايضا
هناك اتفاقيه كبيره
وتمبرمها بين ايران وسوريا حول التجاره
الحره ولكن كل هذه الاتفاقيات وفقا الى
الاحصائيات في داخل ايران لم ترى النور
تاتي الى تفعيلها انا اعتقد همم حضور
الاقتصادي هو ياتي بدرجه الاولى الى روسيا
وبدرجه الثانيه على الرقم من وجود المقاطع
بين تركيا والنظام السوري ولكن هناك كانت
همم
مبادلات تجاريه قويه مع
ونبقى التركي انا في هذه الظروف اعتقد ان
لا يمكن ان النظام همم ياتي ويدخل بهذا
الشكل هناك مناوره واضحه من قبل النظام
الايراني للضغط على الجانب السوري وهناك
اين شروط جديده من قبل بشار الاسد اتجاه
تركيا موضوع الخروج من
شريط الحدودي او الاراضي
فعلا رئيس
كذلك وزير الخارج السوري ولكن همم نعم
وضحت فكره الدكتور حسن ولكن همم استاذ عبد
الحميد هل يمكن القول بان هذا القرار
الجديد هو بدايه ازمه حقيقيه بين ايران
والنظام السوري
لا اعتقد بانها بدايه ازمه ولا اعتقد ان
ها هذه المساله اراها انا بين جذب وشد بين
الطرفين وخاصه بان اليوم الجانب السوري
يرنوا الى ما يتعلق بالحاله التركيه وربما
انا اعتقد بان اظهار الشروط السوريه
واعلانها واعلانها على لسان الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد ووزير الخارجيه اعتقد بانها هي
دليل على ان المساله الترتيبات بين
البلدين باتت قائمه في عنصر اخر الى ذلك
الدخول الامريكي على خط هذه الازمه
والتسريبات التي او عفوا على هذا التقارب
والتسريبات التي تتحدث عن وجود خطه
امريكيه لاحداث تقارب من بين تركيا والقوه
الكرديه المسلحه في شرق الفرات بالتاثير
على المبادره الروسيه كل هذه العوامل
اعتقد بانها
همم مناوره او الهامش مناوره اوسع من جانب
دمشق هذه القضايا فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه
السوريه الايرانيه انا استعد ان يكون هناك
ازمه بمع الازمه الحقيقيه التي قد تؤدي
الى قطيعه التي قد تؤدي الى جمود التي قد
تؤدي الى نهايه لهذا الان لهذه العقود
الاربعه من العلاقه انا اعتقد انها سيكون
هناك كثير من التفاهمات واشير هنا الى ان
وزير الخارجيه السوري في مؤتمر الصحفي مع
نظيره ايراني في دمشق تحدث عن همم امل كما
قال هو عن امل بعد ايام سيظهر عمق العلاقه
السوريه الايرانيه انا اعتقد طهران ليست
بصدد ولا مصلحه لها بان تقطع العلاقه او
شعره معاويه مع دمشق ودمشق ايضا ليس من
مصلحته ان تفرق بحليف كي ايران اصلا وهي
تقول
رومانسيه الاوضاع الداخليه على امل ان
تنجز المصالحه التركيه برعايه
الدكتور حسن هل يمكن القول بان واشنطن همم
تضغط على النظام السوري بيد ايرانيه او
هناك مبالغه في القول ذلك
لا استطيع ان نقول النواه واشنطن من خلال
ايران تضغط على سوريا ولكن اعتقد كما قال
الضيف هناك بعض المبادلات مع التركيه وبعض
السياسه الامريكيه اتجاه تركيا واعطاني
للجانب التركي في هذا الصدد في موضوع
الاتراك في موضوع الاكراد خاصه همم
ما يحدث الان هي مناوره ايرانيه ضد بشار
الاسد من اجل اخباعه الى ما يقولونها
معاهده التعاون الاستراتيجي وانا يمكن
اسميها معاهده الاخضاع الاستراتي لايران
وتعرفون ان
رئيسياتي الى دمشق وسيرركز على ابرام هذه
المعاهده ولذلك همم حدث الان هي مناوره
ايرانيه من اجل الضغط على بشار الاسد
ثم ايران تذهب الاسبوع القادم او يوم غدا
سنشهد هناك في لقاءات بين وزير خارجيه
ايران عبد الله ايان والوزير الخارجيه
الروسي ومن جهه اخرى عبد الله هيان ووزير
الخارجيه التركي ولذلك همم ايران تسعى ان
تخليه ان شاء الله
تتعامل مع تركيا
عبد الحميد توفيق الكتب الصحفي شكرا لكم